such energy and confidence good luck to  the middle of the floor but McKee didn't  realize he was still in the other  direction people on rainbow three did  that come down yet a good walk with was  this when he came over and we had a  conversation with him yesterday he  pointed the Jackson there were the three  ball straight away and a chance at four  keep them off the offensive glass and  not let him score in the post Murphy  picked up by Powell shot clock at five  jumper on the way McKee the record  fletcher mcgee I was never going back  past those skill is back in there for  super Hall Mickey silky-smooth fletcher  mcgee watchword is 29 i know this season  when they shoot 40% or better from the  deal that shot just flip them over 40%  and it's fletcher mcgee from downtown  Wofford's 6 of 20 from the field in the  second half watcher mcgee the three